un petit tour sur les bancs de l'école à
présent avec des professeurs qui
bouleverse un peu les habitudes et qui
propose des classes inversée en clair
les devoirs se font plutôt en classe
pendant la journée et c'est chez eux que
les élèves font connaissance avec la
matière grâce à des capsules vidéo on
voit cela avec arnaud pilet a pas de
rentrer et faustine doit déjà travaillé
au retour de l'école sauf que pour cette
élève tout juste rentré en rhéto pas
d'exercice de devoirs à domicile sa
mission du jour à prendre directement sa
matière via des capsules vidéo on sait
mais tu poses en serre on être en avance
et le regarder autant de fois qu'on veut
vraiment pour nous aider à l'intégrer le
plus facilement le plus vite possible
tandis qu'en classe faut toujours
monsieur s'il vous plaît répétées et
c'est plus dur d'être concentré aussi
que ici on regarde notre vidéo et on va
droit au but et en cinq minutes c'est
fini tout est intégré dans la tête
la théorie apprise au domicile de
l'élève ou même ailleurs cela fait
quatre ans que son prof de géographie et
sciences sociales applique cette méthode
les organisations régionales comme tout
ce qui a trait à l'union européenne
l'alena à l'école 90% cessé de l'écrit
c'est du papier avec de l'écriture
dessus tandis qu'ici on utilise l'image
alors pour un cours comme le cours de
géographie montre aux élèves ce qu'est
vraiment la géographie une discipline
des plus visuel il faut voir les choses
les choses sont des représentations de
l'espace et il est très difficile de
décrire l'espace avec des mots et ça
permet aussi aux profs de se renouveler
dans ce qu'il a dans ce qu'il propose
sylvain drame est réalisée capsule chez
lui tel un youtube hors équipe est
presque comme un pro ils montrent
lui-même ses courtes séquences
didactique mais si la théorie se
dispense désormais en vidéo que
reste-t-il à faire ensuite et c'est pas
fini le travail continue en classe avec
les élèves en classe donc les élèves
réalisent exercice et mise en situation
avec une utilisation
du temps c'est quand on est en classe
que tout peut se faire la remédiation
mais aussi l'apprentissage et tout ce
qu'on peut faire vraiment à la maison on
le fait à la maison
donc c'est repenser l'école est inversée
vraiment le modèle la proche est unique
dans l'école et semble en tout cas
maintenir ses élèves en échec
c'est beaucoup plus motivant entre
guillemets de dire ok je vais aller voir
cette vidéo dans deux minutes tu la
regardes dans la vidéo qui comprend
beaucoup plus facilement ce avec des
images des petits dessins et je joue ça
ouais pédagogique manière en cours on a
le temps de faire des travaux d'analysé
cerveau en classe comme ça on va faire
travaux la maison
les résultats de faustine et la plupart
de ses camarades de classe sont tirés
vers le haut même si de l'avis général
cette idée doit rester une originalité
rafraîchissante